a prisión preventiva para jesús murillo
karam un juez de ciudad de mexico ordenó
que el ex procurador general permanezca
preso hasta el miércoles por presunta
obstrucción a la justicia
desaparición forzada y tortura en el
caso ayotzinapa el sábado la fiscalía
había ordenado la detención de quien
había ejercido el cargo de procurador
durante el gobierno del ex presidente
enrique peña nieto-
se trata de un hito en el caso
catalogado como crimen de estado por la
comisión de la verdad mexicana al ser el
primer arresto de alto nivel murillo fue
cuestionado por liderar la investigación
sobre la desaparición en 2014 de los 43
estudiantes de iguala en el oeste del
territorio mexicano se ha logrado la
pesquisa concluyó en 2015 que los
jóvenes habían sido secuestrados por
supuestos integrantes del cartel
guerreros unidos según la denominada
como verdad histórica el grupo los
habría asesinado y luego habrían sí
logrado sus cuerpos una versión
desmentida por expertos independientes e
incluso rechazada por la onu y las 6h
que es un primer paso para que haya
justicia para que se castigue a quienes
cometieron ese crimen crimen de estado y
también para que se esclarezca lo que
sucedió esa terrible noche en 2015
murillo aseguró continuar con la
investigación hasta detener a los
culpables una promesa incumplida que
siete años después parece comenzar a
materializarse con las órdenes de
captura el exprocurador sino de al menos
80 militares y policías funcionarios
estatales y miembros del cartel
guerreros unidos todos involucrados en
el crimen